- You recently lost your mama
and this book is dedicated to her.
So, how did she inspire it?
- Yeah, I mean,
my mom has been a huge
inspiration in my life.
- That's awesome.
- Yeah,
and I dedicated the book to her
when I found out she had ALS,
and I was gonna dedicate
it to her anyways.
But she died only a few weeks ago.
And she had a stroke when
she gave birth to me,
she's faced so many obstacles in her life,
and it really gave me a
perspective on my life
and how I approach it.
And whenever I have a bad day,
I looked at my mom
and I said, "Well, she
has a positive attitude.
Why can't I?"
So she was such an
inspiration to me and...
it's been hard.
- It's a really beautiful thing, though,
to know that you had that.
Not everybody gets that, right, in life.
It's such a hard thing to grieve.
But, just to know, it's
such a beautiful thing, too,
to have had a mom that
had that kind of impact
that you do something cool
like this, and dedicate it,
and know that it's one of the main reasons
why you got where you are.
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] It's so really
cool to have that.
It's beautiful.
- Thank you.